Kanye West has been suspended from
Twitter again after he tweeted an image
of a swastika hours after praising
Hitler and making anti-semitic jokes in
an interview the American rapper was
only allowed back onto the social media
platform two weeks ago after he was
banned over other anti-semitic posts
comedian David Deal who's campaigned
against anti-Semitism says comments like
West's can have deadly real-world
consequences
beyond the Hitler thing uh which is just
you know gross and crass and offensive
at heart there's this idea that Jews are
somehow and obviously this is what the
Nazis believed as well as believing the
Jews were sub-human that the Jews are
somehow eating away at the fabric of
society and are able to control and
manipulate the rest of humanity in a way
that makes them alien but somehow also
you know the slave masters of the rest
of us and what that leads to is the
killing of Jews
uh David Neil there speaking a bit
earlier well I can speak now to Martin
Stern a holocaust Survivor who survived
two separate Nazi concentration camps he
now works to ensure that the memory of
the Holocaust is not lost and we're very
grateful uh for your time this evening
Martin thank you very much
um when you heard what Kanye West had
said and what he put on Twitter
um well it must make you despair
it's horrifying uh one feels sorry for
the guy he's an idiot in this respect
he's obviously very successful as a
rapper but you know I used to be a
hospital doctor and you think of
Hospital doctors as being clever and uh
ethical and so on I assure you they're
just like the rest of the human race uh
some are very decent people some are not
uh the fact you're good in one field
doesn't mean you're good in another one
and I think Kanye West has fallen into a
trap
of making an easy assumption that baby
runs well with his friends
uh but that could have deadly
consequences indeed yeah as David Bedell
himself was saying um do you think part
of the problem is Holocaust Education
that it's not what it once was
well there are a number of organizations
and uh government efforts and The
Institute of education at the University
of London all doing their best to
improve Holocaust Education in my
personal opinion uh it's only in its
infancy we've been teaching kids Maths
for thousands of years but
Holocaust and genocide education is just
decades old if that
so we have a lot to learn the uh just
telling people what happened in the past
is not sufficient we've got to help
people to understand to a much greater
degree why these things happen
and uh you know the simple view is it's
the action of a few monsters who make
everybody else behave badly the truth is
that perpetrators start off as normal
Ordinary People
and uh Kanye West
is probably uttering views that are
normal in his Social Circle
and which probably seems normal to him
yeah yeah I mean if he if he was
watching this Martin how would you
explain to him the horrors of the
Holocaust um touching on your on your
own personal experience
I don't think Kanye West could do this
if he really knew what happened to my
dad
my dad was arrested on a Dutch Farm
where he was hidden by a staunchly
religious Dutch farmer and his family
he will have been tortured because he
was caught armed
that was routine in those circumstances
he was sent to Auschwitz
he didn't die in Auschwitz he reappeared
in buchenwald in next to the beautiful
cultural town of Weimar five kilometers
outside this place of absolute horror
where he's recorded as having died in
March 45
if Kanye West had some idea of what just
happened to my dad never mind the Six
Million others
he wouldn't make those remarks
only astonishing thing is Kanye West as
a black man
so he will have a back history
in his family of slavery of horrific
maltreatment and since the abolition of
slavery discrimination and other kinds
of maltreatment he has been on the
receiving end of racism
and he's being racist
and he doesn't recognize it
this is not a problem of one particular
group against one other particular group
it is a problem of the human race
and that's takes a lot of getting across
this is where the education has to
improve
but I don't think Kanye West could do
what he's just done
if he really knew more about that sort
of History
yeah you make your point
um extremely well
um we know that 2021 was the highest
year on record for documented reports of
harassment and violence towards Jewish
people 2022 certainly doesn't look as if
it's going to be any better why do you
think we're seeing this right
you know we humans are
tribal territorial
uh you know
tell us Scott that he's an Englishman
and he will bristle at the very least
even with such a slight uh ethnic
difference
and
Judaism is based on a set of ethical
principle it's not called ethical
monotheism for nothing
and
you adopt the behavior of the people you
associate with so there are things about
the Jewish religion which keep Jews
separate from other people to
considerable extent who behave like
normal people and we are indeed normal
people but there are dietary laws and
holidays and so on which mean that we
are distinct
and that makes us an identifiable group
and we're a minority
if you start
abusing a majority you're liable to get
beaten up and defeated but with a
minority you can get away with it
and the other thing is that Jews have
been expelled from countries allowed
back into countries have usually played
a prominent part in the prosperity of
the countries where they've lived
and uh
people become jealous they identify the
Jews as some kind of uh
uh separate group and they attribute
motives which are not there
it's very easy to do
and it it's existed throughout the era
of Christianity and even before read the
Bible you know the Egyptians the
Babylonians the Persians and everybody
in sight try to eliminate the Jews and
some people are still trying
um
you know it
in principle everybody is a racist we're
born that way our instincts work that
way
to make it otherwise
we need education
and the education needs to be more
sophisticated needs to take better
account of what psychologists
neuroscientists sociologists have found
out over the decades
um and
you know civilized Behavior doesn't come
naturally no pre-human ever leapt out of
the Jungle and suddenly created a Doric
column or composed a Shakespearean
sonnet it takes centuries it takes uh
the culture being passed from generation
to generation it takes great thinkers
it's hard work it takes a long time and
we ain't finished you know Gandhi when
he had this image of going around in a
loincloth and
sitting at a spinning wheel arrived in
London for some negotiations and a
journalists shouted to him at Heathrow
Airport Mr Gandhi what do you think of
Western Civilization
and Gandhi's answer was it would be an
excellent idea
it's a joke but
it's civilization as a process
and we haven't finished yeah and Kane
West has just uh Kanye West has just
demonstrated how there is a lot of work
still to do yeah and he would have led
to a great deal I'm sorry if he'd uh if
he'd listen to the last uh 10 minutes or
so Martin Stern uh Holocaust survivor
thank you so much really great to get
you on the program appreciate it